salut les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux
bas que ce qui se passe
plus rien ne fonctionne
mais non rassurez vous ce n'est pas
encore le redouté black out mais ça
pourrait arriver il responsable on le
connaît tous
c'est lui notre soleil un soleil qui
nous plonge dans le noir allez direction
l'atelier est temps de faire rayonner le
savoir
voici l'astre solaire photographiée par
la sonde solar orbiteur le 7 mars
dernier notre étoile est une gigantesque
boule de gaz brûlants son diamètre
mesure 1 million 400 mille kilomètres
cent dix fois celui de notre planète il
est composé d'hydrogène 74% et d'hélium
25% il concentre à lui seul 80 19,8 pour
cent de toute la matière du système
solaire la température de son coeur
atteint 15 millions de degrés c'est un
gigantesque réacteur nucléaire qui
produit de l'énergie toute cette chaleur
mais plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'années à remonter jusqu'à sa surface
où elle est libérée sous forme de
rayonnement
quand il ya bien sûr que la lumière
visible mais aussi des infrarouges des
ultraviolets et beaucoup d'autres
rayonnement que je ne vais pas citer ici
ensuite ça va très vite il faut huit
minutes à la lumière pour parcourir les
150 millions de kilomètres qui séparent
le soleil de la terre ces chiffres sont
astronomiques pour vous donner une
meilleure idée si le soleil faisait la
taille de cette pastèque
la terre ne serait pas plus grosse que
le quart de ce pépin de citron et il
serait situé à 300 mètres de la pastèque
c'est comme si la pastèque se trouvait
au pied de la tour eiffel et le pépin de
citron à son sommet
j'y suis peut-être allé un peu fort mais
du coup vu la distance de quoi faut-il
s'inquiéter des comptes soleil certes
mais pas seulement suis moi
comme la terre
le soleil possède un champ magnétique la
différence c'est qu'ils varient beaucoup
plus vite que celui de notre planète
rendez vous compte les pôles nord et sud
solaire s'inverse en moyenne
tous les 11 pour vous donner une idée la
dernière inversion sur terre s'est
produite il ya grosso modo 780 mille ans
mais revenons au soleil c'est ce que les
scientifiques appellent le cycle solaire
ce cycle rythme l'activité du soleil et
la quantité d'énergie que notre étoile
libère dans l'espace cette énergie ne se
présente pas d'ailleurs uniquement sous
forme de lumière le soleil et met aussi
un flux de particules chargées
électriquement c'est ce qu'on appelle le
vent le solaire notre planète baigne
donc en permanence dans un nuage de
particules
le problème c'est que ce flux continu et
plus ou moins puissants en fonction de
l'activité du soleil quand l'activité
magnétique s'emballe le soleil libère
d'énormes quantités d'énergie ce sont
les fameuses tempête solaire et lorsque
l'activité solaire est vraiment très
intense d'immenses nuages de particules
chargées et de rayonnement sont parfois
cracher dans l'espace pour parle alors d
éjection de masse coronale une tempête
xxl qui voyagent à plus de 2 millions de
kilomètres par heure imaginez un peu la
puissance de ses colères une seule
éruption solaire peut dégager une
quantité d'énergie électrique
équivalente à celle qui seraient
consommées sur terre en cent mille ans
voire un million d'années finalement
j'ai peut-être en mettre une couche
pas de panique est la plupart du temps
notre planète n'a rien à craindre des
humeurs du soleil
elle dispose valu aux deux chocs
l'atmosphère et le bouclier créé par le
champ magnétique terrestre qu'on appelle
la magnétosphère et ce n'est pas de la
science-fiction l'atmosphère et qui
forme une couche d'environ 700
kilomètres d'épaisseur stop une grande
partie des rayons uv elle constitue un
premier bouclier la magnétosphère
ensuite agie jusqu'à 60 mille kilomètres
au dessus de nos têtes
elles nous protègent contre les nuages
de particules chargées que le soleil
nous ouvre cependant le bouclier
magnétique terrestre a un point faible
plus tôt deux au niveau des poules ici
et là c'est par ici que les premiers
effets de l'activité du soleil de ses
colères surtout peut se faire sentir sur
terre on parle alors de tempête
géomagnétique
une des manifestations les plus
courantes de 7 ans pète géomagnétique ce
sont les aurores polaires ses lumières
vertes rouges parfois buret ou rose qui
embrasent le ciel au pôle nord au pôle
sud laisse de la rencontre brutale entre
certaines particules des nuages sont r
et les gaz présents dans notre
atmosphère ce magnifique une aurore
polaire et saône ariane dangereux non tu
as raison mais l'activité solaire peut
avoir des conséquences beaucoup plus
sérieuse
lorsque cet énorme nuage de particules
solaires atteint notre atmosphère il
déforme sa couche supérieure
cette déformation descend jusqu'à 80
kilomètres de la terre la tempête
géomagnétique alors des conséquences
directes sur les systèmes de
communication la transmission des
signaux satellites qui dépend de la
stabilité de l'atmosphère est faussé les
avions et les navires qui s'appuie sur
ses satellites et leurs données gps pour
s'orienter peut se retrouver
temporairement privés de système de
navigation un vrai cauchemar en terme de
sécurité le fonctionnement des
satellites peut carrément être
interrompue endommagés par le
bombardement des particules solaires le
4 février 2022 une tempête géomagnétique
a ainsi mis hors service une quarantaine
de satellites starlink qui venait tout
juste d'être déployés par space x ils
n'ont pas pu se placer en orbite et se
sont désintégrées en retombant dans
l'atmosphère
je savais bien qu'il fallait pas s'en
débarrasser de ces cartes routières et
en cas de tempête géomagnétique
les activités en altitude ou dans
l'espace présente aussi un risque réel
pour la santé humaine
au sol nous sommes protégés par le
double bouclier de l'atmosphère et du
champ magnétique terrestre
mais là où ce n'est pas le cas pour les
astronautes à bord de la station
spatiale internationale qui ne sont pas
protégés par ce bouclier les radiations
peuvent être dangereuses c'est pour
cette raison que certaines zones à bord
sont équipés pour mieux résister aux
rayonnements provoquées par les tempêtes
même chose pour le personnel navigants
des compagnies aériennes les lignes qui
survole les régions polaires les plus
exposés aux tempêtes géomagnétiques sont
parfois dévié pour éviter aux équipages
d'être trop exposés à ces radios
autres risques liés aux tempêtes
géomagnétiques les fameux black out
les nuages de particules solaires chargé
peuvent produire des effets de courant
électrique induit au voisinage du sol
terrestre ces courants peuvent perturber
le fonctionnement des lignes à haute
tension allant parfois jusqu à griller
les transformateurs en bout de ligne et
provoqué des pannes générale
d'électricité c'est ce qui s'est produit
au québec en 1989 plus de 6 millions de
personnes se sont retrouvées sans
électricité
alors qu'on était encore au mois de mars
bah tiens j'ai bien eu réseau de ne pas
me séparer de ma lampe torche qui
fonctionne avec des piles
ben oui s'il n'y a plus d'électricité
impossible de recharger son téléphone et
de s'éclairer avec qu'un d'ailleurs ça
pourrait se reproduire en théorie oui
d'après les calculs d'une équipe
internationale de scientifiques on
aurait déjà évité le pire dans la nuit
du 22 au 23 juillet 2012 deux éruptions
solaires presque simultanées ont
provoqué la plus puissante éjection de
particules solaires jamais observée
heureusement pas dans la direction de la
terre la super tempête géomagnétique qui
aurait pu avoir lieu aurait eu des
conséquences estimé à
2600 milliards de dollars de dégâts le
black out et la désorganisation sur
terre auraient été gigantesque j'ai
demandé à lots de meuse de me réserver
une place dans sa prochaine fusée pour
mars je serai plus en sécurité là-bas
attend quand même un peu pour embarquer
le prochain black hat n'est pas prévu
pour demain
les scientifiques y étudie le phénomène
ont remarqué que les éruptions les plus
violentes se produisent en général sur
des étoiles plus jeune que notre soleil
bah oui avec ses 5 milliards d'années il
en est déjà à la moitié de son existence
il n'est plus aussi actif que dans sa
première jeunesse et même en cas
d'éruptions solaires majeur il faudrait
en plus qu'elles se produisent en
direction de notre planète et d'après
les scientifiques c'est très
hypothétique
ça manque un peu de soleil ici
ah ça fait du bien d'autant
qu'aujourd'hui le soleil et sous haute
surveillance grâce au télescope au
satellite aux sondes qui permettent
d'étudier notre étoile au plus près et
comprendre les mécanismes de
déclenchement des éruptions solaires
parmi ces mécanismes les taches solaires
intéresse plus particulièrement les
scientifiques
ce sont des zones sombres visibles à la
surface de notre étoile elles sont plus
froides que la surface du soleil et le
siège d'une intense activité magnétique
or elles apparaissent peu de temps avant
les éruptions la présence le nombre et
la forme des taches solaires et donc un
bon indicateur d'éventuelles tempêtes
géomagnétiques à venir
toutes ces informations couplée à des
mesures magnétique sur terre permettent
de diffuser aujourd'hui des bulletins
quotidiens de météorologie spatiale
évaluant les risques à court et moyen
terme de coupure des télécommunications
ou d'impact potentiel pour les
personnels navigants mesdames et
messieurs bonsoir l'activité
géomagnétique s'annonce perturbé pour
les prochaines 24 heures avec vous le
voyez un pic aurora l'avancé au dessus
du canada mais rien de très méchant
malgré tout cela augure quelques
perturbations au niveau des satellites
géostationnaires
demain nous fêtons les jamie 2 ou est
bon le prochain pic d'activité solaire
justement avec le risque d'éruption
importante est attendue pour 2025 on a
le temps de voir venir commençait tout
est bien souvenez vous le fameux cycle
solaire de 11 ans qui rythment notre as
le dernier s'est achevée en 2020 en fin
de cycle on est alors au plus bas de
l'activité de coupe le cycle durant onze
ans je le répète en 2025 2026 on sera à
mes parcours du cycle donc au plus fort
de l'activité avant qu'elle ne décline à
nouveau jusqu'en 2031 qu'un cycle
s'achève et qu'un nouveau redémarre
voilà ça nous laisse donc le temps de
voir venir et puis désormais vous ne
serez plus surpris parce que vous en
connaissez un rayon sur les colères du
soleil allez je m'éclipse jusqu'à la
prochaine vidéo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]